so the announcement really could come
any time they could just put that press
statement out boom Stargate is coming
back alongside things like RoboCop
Legally Blonde etc etc because guys
you've got to remember Amazon haven't
actually announced any major MGM
projects since they've took over 18
months ago MGM was in a bit of a state
they've basically now absorbed MGM into
Amazon pictures they have restructured
the business completely they fired a
bunch of people theyve hired a bunch of
people all of that work we believe has
now been done but it did take a long
time we believe RoboCop is coming it's
not been announced Legally Blonde 3 has
actually been in development now for
nearly two years and we've had no update
and obviously that's the film we're most
excited about on this channel